No,
I wouldn't apply the term journalists to
myself.
I think we operate with some,
a journalistic practices,
but by no means what I carry that title.
I think that's a,
a terrible question that's often asked
by a sort of mainstream media for trying
to grasp this.
They're not,
it's not mutually exclusive.
There is journalism that appears on
blogs.
So I guess that's blogging and
journalism.
Um,
and then there are sites like mine that
are journalistic but,
uh,
you know,
aren't sort of hard fast sticking to
that definition.
And then I think you have random
rambling 13 year olds who are printing
whatever idea pops in their head.
And uh,
I think that's just blogging.
Um,
you know,
I think every mainstream publication out
there from time to the New York Times is
trying to jump on this blogging
phenomenon and they are using journalism
to fuel that.
It just happens to appear online in
different forms.